하루만에 휴전이 끝나는 건가 뭐 정말 심각하게 걱정이 되는 그런 상황이고요
아시다시피 이란과 미국이 휴전을 발표를 하면서 지금 시장 분위기가 정말 좋습니다
그런데 암초가 나타났어요 그거 좀 이따가 얘기를 해보고
코스피 어쨌든 오늘 6.8% 시원하게 올랐습니다
그리고 나스닥도 현재 시간 기준으로 3% 오르고 있고
다우도 2.6% S&P500도 2.54% 오르고 있고요
달러원 환율 사실 이렇게 쓰면 안 되는데 이거 관습적으로 잘못 쓰고 있는 이 달러원 환율도
1,477원 그러니까 많이 내려왔습니다
1,500원 찍었었는데 다시 1,400원 중반대로 복귀를 해서 너무 다행이고
원유 가격도 어쨌든 간에 많이 떨어지고 있어요
뭐 십몇 퍼센트씩 떨어져가지고 지금 뭐 94불 이 정도이고요
자 여기까지는 아름다웠는데 조금씩 이상한 일들이 벌어지기 시작을 했습니다
자 첫 번째 있었던 일은 기자회견이었습니다
기자회견에서 일어난 일인데 호르무즈 해업의 통행료에 대해서 트럼프에게 물었더니
트럼프는 미국과 이란이 합작으로 통행료를 부과할 수 있다라는 얘기를 했습니다
합작으로 말이죠 그래서 이거 도대체 뭐지?
아니 미국 지금 미국 뭐하는 거지?
갑자기 미국이 통행료를 부과하겠다라는 정말 신선한 발상을 또 트럼프가 하고 있고요
자 그 외에도 통행료에 대해서 또 여러 가지 얘기가 나오고 있는데
뭐 암호화폐로 지불한다 이런 얘기도 나오고 있고
석유 배럴당 통행료를 징수하는 것도 생각을 하고 있나 봐요
그래서 석유 배럴당 1달러를 요구한다 이런 얘기가 있는데
자 그런데 이 배럴당 수수료는 예전에 알려진 선박당 수수료보다
그때 이제 200만 달러 선박당 200만 달러의 수수료랑 같이 적용될 수도 있다라는 얘기를 하고 있어요
그러니까 이란이 아예 돈을 더 받겠다 이런 얘기도 나오고 있습니다
그런 상황에서 또 트럼프는
이란이 우라늄 농축을 전혀 하지 않을 것이다
그리고 이란의 모든 핵과 관련된 걸 없앨 것이다 이런 얘기를 했어요
그러니까 이것이 나중에 협상에 되게 쟁점이 될 수가 있는데
우라늄 그리고 핵무기와 관련된 걸 어떻게 할 거냐
이걸 가지고 협상이 정말 첨예하게 될 가능성이 높을 것 같습니다
트럼프가 이것에 대해서 물러나지 않겠다라는 어떤 의지를 천명했기 때문에
다만 조금 긍정적인 것은 트럼프가 이란의 관세와 재배가
제재 완화에 대해서 논의를 하고 있다라고 얘기를 했기 때문에
이런 건 좀 긍정적이죠
자 그런데 여기서 갑자기 누가 큰 똥을 쌌어
큰 문제를 일으켰는데 누구냐 바로 이스라엘입니다
이스라엘이 레바논을 공격했는데
상당히 큰 종류의 큰 규모의 공격이었어요
제가 캡처한 기준으로 89명인데 100명이 넘었더라고요 아까 보니까
이스라엘이 레바논을 공격했는데
레바논이 또 이란과 사이가 좋거든요
그러니까 이란의 친구를 공격했는데
이렇게 생각을 하시면 됩니다
이스라엘 군은 10분 동안 레바논 전역의 여러 지점을 대상으로
100회의 공습을 단행했다라고 발표를 했어요
그러니까 이거 진짜 아니 지금 싸우지 않기로 했는데 갑자기
그리고 굳이 이스라엘이 이런 트러블을 만드나 이런 생각이 들죠
그래서 레바논 지역이 과연 휴전할 때 해당이 되냐
이거에 대해서 말이 좀 많은데
파키스탄 총리는 파키스탄이 참고로 중재자인데
역할을 했죠 이번 회담에서
파키스탄 총리의 발표에 따르면 레바논도 이 휴전에 적용이 되는데
네타냐후 이스라엘의 총리는 아니 적용되지 않는다라고 말을 하고 있습니다
자 여기에 이란 당연히 열받죠
그래서 빠기친 이란이 이스라엘이 레바논 휴전을 위반했다
공격을 검토하고 있다라는 얘기를 하면서
원래 사실 장이 더 크게 상승했거든요
3.5% 막 3.9% 이렇게 했잖아요
어제도 상승했었던 나스닥이 살짝 상승세가 이 뉴스 때문에 사라졌어요
트럼프 같은 경우는 pbs와의 인터뷰를 통해서
레바논은 합의에 포함이 안 됐고 이것은 별개의 교전이다 라고 얘기를 했습니다
뭐 이거는 당사자들만이 알 수 있는데
이스라엘은 지금 극대노하고 있잖아요
왜 이스라엘이 이렇게 심통을 부렸는지 약간은 알 수 있는 기사가 있었는데
월스트리트 저널에 따르면 이스라엘은 휴전 합의에 대해 늦게 통보 받았다고 하고요
그렇기 때문에 기뻐하지 않았다 라고 합니다
자 그래서 이스라엘이 혼자 삔또가 상한 것 같아요
그래서 이런 일을 저지르지 않았나 뭐 이런 생각이 들고
그러다 보니까 파키스탄 총리가 다시 성명을 발표했는데
야 당사자들 휴전의 당사자들 제발 좀 카운트다운 하세요
제발 화내지 마세요 라고 이렇게 얘기를 했습니다
말려보려고 하는 거죠
일단 뭐 건너가야 될 산이 참 많은 것 같습니다
2주 동안의 협상이 이루어지는지도 중요한데
여기서 또 이스라엘이라는 변수까지도 끼어 들어가지고
이스라엘은 사실 뭐 자기 맘대로 할 수 있으니까
아 이게 또 원래 같았으면 트럼프가 타코하고 싶으면 타코할 수가 있는데
타코할 수가 없는 게 가장 큰 문제가 아닌가
이스라엘이라는 존재가 가장 큰 문제가 아닌가 싶고
네타냐후가 8분 전에 기자회견을 했는데
이런 또 진짜 열받네
지금 전 세계인들이 고통받는 거 신경도 안 쓰이나봐요
그래서 이스라엘이 전쟁에서 거대한 성과를 거두었고
이스라엘은 필요할 때 언제든 전쟁을 재개할 태세를 갖추고 있고
이것은 전쟁의 종식이 아니라
목적 달성을 향한 중간 정거장이다
이렇게 얘기를 하고 있습니다
그래서 이스라엘이 가장 골치가 아프다
라고 생각이 되는 뭐 그런 얘기였고요
AI 얘기도 조금 해 보면
메타에서 드디어 정말 오랜만에
새로운 인공지능 모델을 발표했습니다
지난번에 발표했었던 라마와는 다르게
이제는 클로즈드 소스
그러니까 재미나이나 채찌피티 뭐 클로드처럼
그냥 이제 오픈소스가 아닌 그런 모델을 발표를 했고요
그 당시에 뭐 여러분들 아시겠지만
MSL이라고 해서 메타 슈퍼 인텔리전스 랩이라는
그런 나름대로의 드림팀을 메타에서 만들어서
돈을 엄청 줘서
좋은 그런 컴퓨터 과학자들을 영입해서 팀을 만들고
거기서 처음서부터 정말 제로 베이스로 이 모델을 만들었다고 해요
알고 보니까 제 전 직장 동료이자 학교 후배가 여기 있더라고
그래서 좀 물어보고 싶긴 한데
오히려 또 애매해
이것도 물어보기가 좀 그런 부분이 있네요
어쨌든 뭐 이거 중요한 건 아니고
어쨌든 그래서 뮤즈 스파크라는 새로운 모델을 출시를 했습니다.
그러면서 이제 벤치마크 스코어를 발표를 했는데요
이 파란색이 뮤즈 스파크인데
이거 살짝 약간 좀 애매한 부분이 있어
뭐가 애매하냐
자기가 1등인 거랑 1등이 아닌 거를 제대로 표시를 안 했습니다
그래서 1등인 것만 표시를 하면 이런 식으로 표시가 되고요
여전히 많은 벤치마크는
재미나의 3.1%가 제일 잘 나온 상황이다 라고 볼 수가 있겠습니다
그러나 이제 몇 가지는 그래도 또 뮤즈 스파크라는
이 새로운 모델이 1등을 하는 부분도 있다
이렇게 볼 수가 있고요
다만 AI 모델을 제가 이제 많이 써보다 보니까 느끼는 게
벤치마크만 봐서는 알 수가 없고요
실제 사용 체험기 입소문이 되게 중요한 것 같아요
제가 이런 얘기를 하는 게
저는 클로드 홀릭이거든요
지금 클로드만 쓰고 있는데
클로드 오퍼스는 사실 비싸서 자주는 안 쓰고
클로드로 치면 이제 한 소넷 정도를 주로 많이 쓰는 것 같은데
클로드가 보시면 벤치마크 점수는 그렇게 높지가 않아
벤치마크가 클로드가 1등하는 게 딱 하나밖에 없어
소프트웨어 엔지니어링 벤치마크밖에 없어요
그러니까 벤치마크 점수만 보면
클로드가 그렇게 좋은 것 같지 않은데
이게 써보면 정말 좋습니다
압도적으로 좋습니다
그래서 저는 지금 클로드가 초각차가 벌어져 있는 것 같거든요
근데 벤치마크 점수는 낮기 때문에
이 뮤즈 스파크를 그냥 겉만 보고
메타가 이제 따라왔구나라고 생각하기에는
조금 더 저는 시장의 반응
주변 사람들의 반응을 좀 더 지켜보고
판단을 해야 될 것 같습니다
어쨌든 요즘 입소문 원탑은 클로드고요
가장 최근에 정말 의미 있었던 사건이 있는데
이 Annualized Revenue 그냥 뭐 편의상 매출이라고 할게요
이 매출이 가장 최근 데이터로는
클로드를 만드는 엔트로픽이 오픈 AI를 추월한 걸로 알려져 있어요
왜? 요즘에 이 엔트로픽이 만든 클로드가 정말 미쳤거든요
그래서 클로드의 모델의 성능이 너무 좋아서
뭐 써보시는 분들 아실 거라고 생각합니다
제 주변에 지금 쓰는 사람들이 너무 많아 가지고
제가 알기로는 한국도 클로드가 채찍피티 사용자를 넘어섰다
뭐 이런 뉴스도 봤던 것 같은데
클로드 폼이 요즘 진짜 미쳤고
그런 상황 속에서 과연 메타가 의미 있는 반격을 할 수 있을지
좀 지켜볼 필요가 있을 것 같고요
근데 시장에서는 정말 환호를 한 거 같아요
물론 시장이 기본적으로 좋은 분위기긴 했지만
이번 출시를 보고 갑자기 급등을 더 했습니다
원래도 상승세긴 했지만 더 상승을 해서
메타가 현재 8% 상승하고 있다
이 새로운 모델 출시에 대해서
시장이 매우 환영하고 있음을 알 수가 있겠죠
그 외에도 트렌드포스라는 반도체 관련된 미디어 회사에서
뭘 발표를 했냐면
엔비디아의 새로운 칩 루빈이 출시 지연 위험에 직면했다라는 얘기를 했습니다
공급망 이슈와 지정 확정 문제 때문에
새로운 GPU의 출시 일정이 늦어지면서
예상 점유율이 낮아질 거다라는 얘기가 나오면서
엔비디아는 좀 상승폭이 꺾였어요
현재 엔비디아 1.95% 상승하고 있습니다
자 뭐 전쟁은 터지고 우리는 너무 힘들지만
어쨌든 AI는 계속 가고 있다고 볼 수 있는 차트가 있는데
이 자료를 보시면 내려가면 내려갈수록
AI를 내려가면 내려갈수록
특정 AI 반도체를 많이 사용하고 있다라는 건데
지금 보시면 아시겠지만
모든 이 그래프가 다 밑으로 내려가고 있지 않습니까
이게 쓰기가 힘들다라는 거거든요
그러니까 모든 사람들이 클라우드에서
엔비디아 GPU를 쓰려고 하다 보니까
가용성이 매우 낮다라는 거를 보여주는 그래프인데
정말 충격적인 건 뭐냐면
이 A100조차 이 A100이 요 색깔인데
A100조차 쓸 수 있는 A100이 거의 없거든요
거의 없어 지금 클라우드에서
참고로 A100이 언제 나왔냐
엔비디아 A100 출시일이 2020년 6월이에요
그러니까 6년 전에 나온 엔비디아 GPU도
사용하기가 매우 어려운 상황입니다
그 정도로 지금 AI 컴퓨팅에 대해서
세상이 미쳤다 라고 보시면 될 거 같고요
제가 3월 중순부터 4월 초까지 유럽 여행을 다녀왔는데
유튜버 Turbo83님이랑 같이 갔습니다
그리고 또 다른 전업투자자 지인들이랑 같이 갔는데
그거 관련된 영상들이 다 같이 갔는데
영상들이 아마 계속 업로드가 될 거예요
터보님 채널에 업로드가 되는데
공동 저자로 해서 아마 여러분들한테도 영상들이 노출이 될 건데
궁금하신 분들은 봐주시면 정말 감사하겠고요
갑자기 무슨 여행 영상이 계속 올라오냐
이렇게 좀 생뚱맞아 하실 것 같아서
미리 말씀을 드리는 겁니다
그래서 같이 이렇게 유럽을 갔다 왔다 라고 보시면 되고
터보님이 이제 람보르기니 차를 뽑은 거고
저는 그냥 따라만 간 겁니다
참고로 말씀드리면 유럽을 같이 한번 가보고 싶어서 따라왔다
이렇게 보시면 되고
터보님이 람보르기니 차를 뽑은 거고 저는 그냥 따라만 간 겁니다 참고로 말씀드리면 유럽을 같이 한번 가보고 싶어서 따라왔다 이렇게 보시면 되고
지금 지구촌이 전쟁 중이나 보니까
참 이런 영상들을 올리는 것도 조심스러운 부분들도 있는 것 같습니다
불편하신 분들에게는 좀 죄송하다는 말씀도 드리고요
어쨌든 저는 또 다음 영상으로 돌아오도록 하겠습니다